JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello, and
welcome to "YouTube Developers
Live." Today, we have an
exciting show for you.
We'll talk about gaming.
Let me introduce our guests.
Wayne Karo from Free
Range Games.
How are you doing, Wayne?
WAYNE KARO: Great.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: What do
you do at Free Range?
WAYNE KARO: I'm the director
of products.
And I fill-in a lot of holes,
do business development,
coding, whatever it takes.
We're quite a small development
studio, and we're
making all kinds of games.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And Kevin Wang from Kamcord.
How are you doing, Kevin?
KEVIN WANG: Good.
How are you?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank
you for coming.
This is your second appearance
on our live show.
KEVIN WANG: That's
right, yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I guess the
last time wasn't too bad,
since you decided
to come back?
KEVIN WANG: It's worth
coming back for.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And tell us
one more time what do you do
at Kamcord?
KEVIN WANG: I'm one of
the co-founders.
And I basically work a
lot on the code and
the client-side SDK.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, great.
So you are doing some coding.
And hopefully we'll get
into that later
on in the show today.
All right, great.
So let's just talk a little
bit about Free
Range Games and gaming.
And one thing that I wanted to
cover today is, what does
video have to do with
mobile games?
We see more and more companies
integrating video uploads into
their mobile games.
I wanted our audience to
understand better why you guys
do that, and why you see
any value in it.
So maybe, Wayne, starting with
you, tell us more about Free
Range Games.
How did you guys get started?
And a little bit of a history
of the company.
And then we'll talk about your
product that we'll be
featuring today.
WAYNE KARO: OK, Free
Range Games started
at the end of 2009.
A group of guys from Activision
and a studio that
was around for quite a
while, Shaba Games,
formed Free Range Games.
And it started with about 20
game designers, artists,
software engineers.
And started working
on games in Unity.
Specifically, browser games for
Facebook, trying to bring
that console-quality experience
to a Facebook game.
But then about a couple of years
into that, the market
kind of changed.
And we decided to start making
mobile games, as well as
continuing with some browser
and PC-downloadable games.
But everything in Unity.
The Unity engine allows us to
make these games that are
cross-platform.
And now, over half of our
efforts are in mobile games.
We launched several last year.
And we're going to launch
several more this year and
continue with that.
A lot of our company's
background is
in 3D action games.
Shaba Games was the studio that
worked on "Tony Hawk,"
for example.
So a lot of those guys in our
company have that kind of
experience.
And we think that video of
action sports is exciting, and
video of action games
is also exciting.
And it's a good way to show off
the 3D games that we make.
So we thought, about a
year ago, that this
would be a nice concept.
You and I were working
on a project earlier.
And then along came some
start-ups, like Kamcord.
And we started working
with them recently.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And for those of you that might
have watched a session
from Google I/O 2012 about
video gaming, Wayne was
actually one of the
presenters.
So this is what he alluded
to in his conversation.
So you mentioned that you're
working with Kamcord.
And how does Kamcord fit
into this project
that we'll talk about?
WAYNE KARO: Sure.
Well, the basic idea is, how
do we get video off of a
mobile phone and up
onto YouTube?
And tools or services, like
Kamcord's, allow us to do that
really easy.
They take care of all of the
video capture and sharing
capability.
And we don't have to, as game
designers, worry about all of
the nuts and bolts that go with
that and the layout of
that interface.
Like many other third-party
services, we could just plug
it right in, and it's
ready to go.
So we wanted to get
that feature.
To build that would be a
lot of extra effort.
And it's nice that we can use
a free service like this.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So without further ado, should
we try to maybe take a look to
see how that looks
in practice?
I know you brought your tablet
here with a game that you guys
have built and has
this capability.
Maybe you will transition
to a little demo.
WAYNE KARO: Sure.
Our game is "APO Snow." This is
a snowboarding game that we
made for our partner, APO.
They're an actual
snowboard/skiing brand.
It will be a little bit
difficult for me to play and
talk at the same time.
So we just basically want to get
down the mountain and be
able to show you guys kind of
what it will look like when we
upload a video.
So APO, like I said, is an
actual ski/snowboarding brand.
They sponsor a lot of pro
athletes that are
featured in the game.
And the designs for the
snowboard and the skis in the
game are actual product that
this company sells.
So you can get the look of an
actual pro athlete using the
APO goods in the game.
And we try to make
the experience
as casual as possible.
You notice I'm just using
one finger to
carve down the mountain.
And the tricks are really
easy to do.
And when you get done with the
run, you can write a little
message and then share this
replay on YouTube.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So while this is uploading,
Kevin, can you tell us a
little bit about what happened
under the hood, like what was
actually happening?
KEVIN WANG: Yeah.
So basically, in terms of
Kamcord API and iteration,
there were some calls that were
made basically to tell
the SDK to start and stop
the video capture.
So at the beginning of the run
down the mountain, they said
to start recording.
We started capturing all the
frames that were basically
displayed on the screen.
At the end, after you tell it
to stop recording-- and
basically, there's a way to
show the UI, which you saw
earlier, which allowed him to
type a message, watch the
video replay, and share onto
Facebook, Twitter,
YouTube, via email.
And so basically, that was just
all behind the scenes
with a couple API [INAUDIBLE].
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Does the frame
capture happen in real
time while the game
is playing?
KEVIN WANG: Yeah.
It happens in real time.
It saves the video
to the device.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: What
type of overhead do
you think that incurs?
KEVIN WANG: Most of the time
it's pretty small, actually.
Yeah, for most games that
we see, they're already
at their max FPS--
30 or 60 FPS.
It tends to stay there.
So it's a pretty
small overhead.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
WAYNE KARO: Yeah, I'd like
to just respond to that.
That's one of the things we're
really pleased with.
We tend to max out the processes
on our game, and
always are trying
to get the frame
rate as high as possible.
Because that allows for a
better 3D experience.
And so we were very nervous that
the frame rate would take
a significant hit.
But throughout the entire
game, you can't
notice it as a player.
And if you look on one of our
optimizer tools, it's only a
frame rate or two that
we're taking hits.
So it's really good.
I'm really pleased with it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And the video upload has
completed by now.
So what happens next?
WAYNE KARO: OK, so you could go
to YouTube and the video is
actually there.
And we can watch my unskillful
playing, one finger from the
side while I'm talking.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Actually, that
was a good demonstration
of what you said earlier about
the ease of your controls.
Because one thing I like about
your games is it's always very
easy to actually navigate
whatever it is that you're
actually trying to achieve,
versus trying to move the
device around or something
like that.
So I think I'm always
very pleased with
how the design works.
I'm sure a lot of thought goes
into the touch controls and
how the traditional controller
capabilities are actually
translated into this new
world of mobile gaming.
I think that's critical to
building a good game.
WAYNE KARO: Yeah, we do give
it a lot of thought.
And we tend to develop controls
unique for each game.
It's one of the areas that
we have a passion for.
So each one of our games
is different.
In this particular one, we've
tried to go very casual with
the controls.
In other games, we have much
more involved, more hardcore
controls, just depending on the
nature of the game that
we're developing.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So let's talk
a little bit more about
the technical aspects
of this work.
So starting with implementation
technology, so
you mentioned the game is
implemented in Unity?
WAYNE KARO: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
For people that are not familiar
with Unity, can you
tell us a little bit more about
what does Unity do?
WAYNE KARO: Yeah, Unity
essentially allows you to make
3D games very easily.
And it's a tool that is
actually used for even
different kinds of media beyond
3D games-- any time
you're doing a 3D simulation.
But it's become very popular
in the gaming world.
If you go to any of the
conferences, like Game
Developer Conference or
E3, you can see a
lot of examples now.
Many of the mobile games on
Google Play and the Apple App
Store are made in Unity
these days.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
Cool.
And then, the part that actually
performs the video
capture, video encoding, video
upload, is something that
Kevin, your company
implements, right?
KEVIN WANG: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And how
is that implemented?
KEVIN WANG: Yeah.
Basically, behind the scenes,
we hook it in the raw OpenGL
recording in the engine.
So we kind of intercept a lot
of rendering, do some extra
work on the side to capture
the frames.
Send it off to the [INAUDIBLE]
as video, as MP4.
So that's all basically
happening
on a different thread.
But basically the core stuff is
down at the OpenGL level.
We had to do a lot of management
of the frames and
stuff like that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And for
someone who is building a
mobile game, how do they
integrate the capabilities?
Is there a library that
they link with?
What's the actual process?
KEVIN WANG: Yeah.
Basic iOS is a very
simple framework.
You go to our site, sign
up, and download.
Entirely free.
And basically, it's very
drag and drop.
Basically, it's a framework
you link against.
And the actual integration
process is
very simple, actually.
From the time you download it to
the actual set up, in terms
of getting a test video
recorded, should take maybe 5,
10 minutes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
KEVIN WANG: Yeah, the API
is very straightforward.
Just start recording
and stop recording.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then,
you use the YouTube API to
actually upload the video
to YouTube, right?
Are you using YouTube API
v2 or v3 for that?
KEVIN WANG: Right now
we're still on v2.
But we're planning on upgrading
to v3 very soon.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So one question that we
typically like to ask on this
show is, is there anything
surprising that you have
encountered while working
on this project?
And is this your first game
that has the video upload
capability?
WAYNE KARO: Yeah, that's true.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Anything that
you have learned by going
through this process?
I know you've always been trying
to push the envelope,
and you have a lot of great
ideas about video game play
and multiplayer and
things like that.
So I'm curious to kind of poke
your brain, see what happened.
WAYNE KARO: I think the
most surprising thing
was just the results.
We injected the Kamcord feature
right in the middle of
the game play.
As you saw in the demo, you
finished the run, it comes up
right there.
I expected that we would have
a lot more people actually
sharing video than they did.
Recently, we ran a promotional
campaign and had about 180,000
new users come into the game.
At the same time, we updated
the game and it included
Kamcord for the first
time at that point.
We saw about 7% of those
users actually
upload a video to Kamcord.
And then, in total across
YouTube, Twitter, Facebook,
and email, it was about a
percent or so that actually
shared from that point.
I guess the biggest surprise--
I had a higher expectation that
there would be a lot more
video sharing.
Because one of the prime
motivators that we had to put
this in from a business
standpoint was the
discoverability of our game.
Many of the people that uploaded
videos, if you go on
YouTube, you look at the
views, they only
have a couple views.
That's fine, because people are
primarily uploading for
their friends to take a look at
and maybe family members.
Not everybody is a PR machine.
But I hoped that there were
upwards of 50,000 or more
video uploads for
the same time.
Granted, maybe not everybody's
happy with the results of the
first time they're playing.
They don't want to show their
scores off or the runs, like I
just showed, that
was pretty sad.
So that could be part of it.
I think one thing that we
can do is have a deeper
integration into the game.
We, like I said, just put it
right into the game flow.
And that was easy enough,
but we didn't think
deeper about it.
Perhaps what we should do is
something like when the player
has a really awesome run, gets
a high score or a gold medal,
then pop it up at that point
and say, hey, you did an
awesome job.
Why don't you share this?
To make it a little bit more
special and like a reward.
And even though the numbers
might not increase at that
point, maybe we see a little
bit more sharing.
So there's things like that
that we could do.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
That's actually very
good insight.
Thank you.
Thank you for sharing that.
How about you, Kevin?
Anything on the technical front
that came up during the
integration?
KEVIN WANG: I think in terms
of the tech stuff, it was
pretty straightforward.
I think in terms of the end
user behavior, we saw some
interesting things.
We found that people tend to
share a lot-- so right now the
options are YouTube, Facebook,
Twitter, and email.
Or they can share directly to
Kamcord without any of those.
We do find that any of these
logins sort of have a drop-off
in the funnel.
So we tend to see more people
will share to just Kamcord
directly without picking any
of those four choices.
But people tend to like to share
actually a lot through
Facebook and email.
That was actually the
two most popular.
I think part of it is
just that people--
with email, they can just send
an email to a few people that
they want to share it
with particularly.
With Facebook, there's
a lot of people
on Facebook, obviously.
And that's a part of people's
daily lives.
I think in terms of YouTube, I
think people don't necessarily
recognize that they even have
an account at YouTube.
I'm sure many people
use Gmail.
But they're less aware
that those are one
and the same now.
And the log in process is--
anytime you have a login box,
the funnel just narrows a lot
at that point.
So I think just some simple
things, like for Facebook,
even integration to iOS 6,
basically they don't have to
enter their information
at all.
Whereas with YouTube there's
one extra login that causes
the funnel to drop
a little bit.
That's where we found.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
And are you guys using the
WebView-based GTM 2 OAuth
controller for the OAuth flow?
KEVIN WANG: Yes, we are.
That was actually very
easy to use.
You basically just drop it in.
It takes care of all
the login for you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
For those of you that are
watching and didn't catch that
part, we do have an open source
project, Safari OS
applications, you can
just integrate.
I'll just share a link
to that project.
So to implement the video upload
capability on the OAuth
2 flow, it's actually quite
easy to do that.
And this is what Kamcord is
using in order to log-in the
user and obtain the OAuth 2
permission so that the video
can be uploaded on
their behalf.
Additionally, as Kevin
mentioned, if you have a
Google account, such as a Gmail
account, you're actually
very close to be able to upload
the videos to YouTube.
There is an additional step
that must be performed for
people that don't have a
YouTube account yet.
Namely, they need
a user channel.
But that is also something
that we recently made
available to application
developers
through a WebView process.
So for folks that have a Google
account and they don't
have a YouTube channel yet, we
have a create channel URL,
which will basically take the
user through the channel
creation flow, and then return
to a point which you can
recognize in your WebView.
And then close the WebView and
proceed with the upload.
So we're trying to
make it easy.
But as you said, I think this
is always a hurdle whenever
people have to login
yet again.
Because mobile is very
transactional and quick.
So one thing that I found is
people have a little bit of
time, they play a little game
and they want to move on.
They don't want to spend too
much time dealing with stuff.
So we really need to make
it as smooth and
transparent as possible.
Yeah, I mean, that's perhaps--
also the user experience may
be-- that should be something
done earlier in the process.
So when they register or
whatever, they have an option
to actually go through that
OAuth flow when they
actually have time.
Because once that is done and
you have the refresh token,
then you can actually use it.
And they can upload
it, basically
frictionlessly, at any point.
Great.
Anything on the API side, any
feedback about things that you
think we should be implementing
that we're not yet?
Or any kind of general
API feedback?
KEVIN WANG: Overall, it's
been pretty easy to use.
I think we're using all
the most of the basic
functionalities.
I'm not sure if this is in the
pipeline or you guys are
working on this, but the ability
to kind of manage more
of the channel stuff
from an API side.
That's my only thing.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
We don't have much of that
exposed, other than playlist
management capabilities.
One thing we are doing that is
relevant to this use case in
API v3-- and again, this is why
I ask you if you're using
v3, because we do have
some extra features.
So one thing that typically
comes up in these use cases is
when you upload a video, we
actually transcode it to all
the different formats.
And then that process can take
a while, and it's not
synchronous with the
video upload.
It happens asynchronously.
So if the video's shredded a
little too early, chances are
somebody who is watching it on
the device that does not yet
support it by the transcode will
not be able to watch it.
KEVIN WANG: I see.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So in API
v3, we actually have this
progress API.
So you can actually check on the
processing status and see,
have all the transcode
completed?
So in this use case, you
uploading the video will
actually transcode it
to H.264 web band
for different devices.
And then theoretically, it
should really only be shared
once all the transcode
is completed.
Because this will guarantee
that whoever picks up the
video from, say, social media,
will be able to watch it.
So this is something we have
in the API v3, so I highly
encourage you to get it.
But that's something we're
doing to make it easier.
And as far as the channel
management--
yeah, this is good feedback.
Because going back to what Wayne
said, I think helping
the users to feature that
content, then it's really
going to drive the objectives
that you guys have for this
type of integration.
And I've seen this before.
For me, it's kind of like if a
tree falls in the forest, no
one notices.
So if the views are very low
for this content, then it's
really sub-optimal.
And what we've seen looking
at some of the larger
integrations we've done with
the console makers is,
realistically, this is a very
Long Tail distribution.
So there's a few number of
videos that have a large
number of views, and everything
else has reasonably
small number of views.
But we do need to get to the
point where for mobile sharing
you will have that Long Tail
with a few ones being actually
used to promote the game or
some accomplishments and
things like that.
KEVIN WANG: Yeah.
Actually, to that point about
making the video easier to
find-- and Wayne mentioned
this before--
thinking about deeper
integration where when
basically really cool things
happen, you want to expose the
API and let them share.
I think that's a good idea.
Some other very simple things
that people who use the API
can do, just to set all the tags
for the metadata rights.
And that makes it much
more easier to serve.
Stuff like that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
Cool.
All right, anything else you
would like to share with us?
Or are you going to go
back and design yet
another awesome game?
WAYNE KARO: Yeah.
Kevin and I were just talking
about that the other day.
What's the next step?
We are going to continue working
on "APO Snow." We've
got some good things in
development there.
So we hope to continue to expand
the game and perhaps
even do a sequel.
And then we have a lot
of other games that
we're working on.
We have a shooter.
It's pretty fun.
It's got a lot of traction
on the web.
We're bringing it to mobile.
Right now it's on Android.
It requires wireless controllers
to play it.
We don't have the touch
controls yet.
But hopefully in a few
months we're further
down the road there.
And we're talking about, what
are the possibilities for this
Kamcord video recording
technology?
Because in that particular
game, a session could be
upwards to 20 minutes long.
How do you record
and all of that?
But fortunately, in a shooter,
kill streaks is a
great way to show off.
So if we just cut around every
time you get a kill for the
kill streak, then naturally
videos get longer and longer
with more kill streaks.
For those videos that are
uploaded, players can easily
search on, like 30 kill streaks,
50 kill streaks.
And they'll be obviously
fewer of those videos.
But they probably will look
cooler and cooler because the
better, more skillful players
are playing those.
So it could be some exciting
watching without all the rest
of the stuff that's happened
in the game.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yep.
I think that you bring
a very good point.
I mean, we are still very
early in this process.
I think PC games and console
games have done quite
a bit in this area.
And some of them have a theater
mode with editor
capability, slow-motion
capability, and so forth.
Like, for example, "Call
of Duty" does this.
But we're just getting
started on mobile.
And I definitely agree that if
the game can signal, to a
technology like yours, some of
the additional information to
decide which content is actually
interesting to
showcase, it'll be great.
And it's a general use
case in video.
You have a lot of content, how
do you make it interesting?
What actually cut?
I think whoever solves
that problem will
be a very rich person.
All right, let's transition
to questions.
We have a few questions
from the audience.
So there's one question
for you, Kevin.
If you're not using Unity, can
you still use Kamcord?
KEVIN WANG: Yeah.
We support any game
built for iOS.
So all you need--
we have a plug-in you can
download and install.
Otherwise, it's a simple frame
where you can drag in.
And we also have the docs online
for how to do that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Great.
And then related question, are
there any other titles that
have integrated Kamcord?
KEVIN WANG: Yeah.
There are a few.
One is called "Slingshot Racer."
I think it was one of
the Unity award winners
last year.
A few others.
We're integrating right now with
"Scramble with Friends."
Basically doing a test
integration with them that
should be out in the
coming few months.
So those are some games
that come to mind.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
And then, another question
about the discovery
optimization.
So the question is, what are
the tips on metadata that
would help with discovery
and maximizing views?
Any knowledge you could
share in the SEO area?
KEVIN WANG: Yeah.
I think for that two major
things come to mind.
And the first is basically we
allow the user to enter a
title for the video.
And if they do, that
would be the title.
But oftentimes, users
are kind of lazy.
They just want to press Share.
And if that's a case,
we allow you to
basically set the title.
And so basically, after every
round or level or however your
game is structured, we
definitely recommend you
change that tile to match what
happened in the video.
So that makes every video
title different.
So when people are searching
online, they can see what they
want to find.
Maybe you got three stars or
a certain time for a level,
something like that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So this is
something that the game
developer can set up
in Kamcord as a
part of video upload?
You basically give a callback
capability or configuration
capability, right?
So the point is, just make sure
that whatever happened in
the game is actually reflected
in the title before you invoke
the upload operation.
KEVIN WANG: Exactly.
Yeah.
But basically, right after you
call a stop recording and the
video clip has ended, you can
set all this information about
the video, with the title
and stuff like that.
So I think the title is one
of the very big things.
And somebody else suggested
all the tags for YouTube.
We definitely recommend that
you change all the tags.
You add your gaming and
stuff like that.
And you add whatever information
about that video
that was just recorded.
That makes a little
bit of difference.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
KEVIN WANG: Makes a
big difference.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So one more question.
I think this one is
addressed at me.
Is YouTube Developer
Operations hiring?
And yes, we are hiring.
For more information, go to
developers.google.com/jobs.
OK, so I think this is all
the time we have today.
Thank you very much
for coming.
And for those of you watching,
thank you for your time.
We'll see you again
live on "YouTube
Developers Live" next week.
Bye.